History looping through your throat. Cold machines warns your soft, sad laughing notes, get carried through the tangled wires. Cold machines. You sing and something in the house. Hey guys, it's Joel, and thank you for tuning into part two of Therapy on the Couch, Psycho History of American Psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't, and why it has trouble telling the difference. By the 1920s, America had a problem that no amount of brass instruments or behavioral conditioning could solve. It didn't know where it was going.
历史在你的喉咙里循环。冰冷的机器警告着你那柔弱、悲伤的笑声，被带入纠缠的电线中。冰冷的机器。你歌唱，屋子里有些东西。嘿，伙计们，我是乔尔，感谢收听《沙发上的治疗：美国心理学心理史》第二部分。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分两者。到了20世纪20年代，美国面临一个任何铜管乐器或行为调节都无法解决的问题。它不知道自己要去向何方。
And this wasn't abstract. It was felt in the bones of every office worker sitting in a skyscraper, but not building one. Wondering what his grandfather, who sat on the beam outside his window, would have thought of him. It was felt in the chest of all the young women who had moved from the farm to the city and discovered that the the rules from the farm no longer applied. The hierarchies were gone. The traditions were no longer valid. And it was felt in the sleeplessness of every immigrant who had crossed the ocean to find that America was not this golden land of opportunity, but a confusing and chaotic place where the structure of the old world failed to provide the same certainties.
这并非抽象概念。每一个坐在摩天大楼里却不是在建造它的人，都能从骨子里感受到这一点。他会想，坐在窗外横梁上的祖父会怎么看他。每一个从农场搬到城市，发现农场的规则不再适用的年轻女性，都能从胸口感受到这一点。等级制度消失了。传统不再有效。每一个跨越海洋来到美国，却发现这里并非充满机遇的黄金乐土，而是一个旧世界的结构无法提供同样确定性的混乱之地，在失眠中感受到了这一点。
The previous generation had known what they were doing. They were going to tame the frontier or build the railroad or establish the homestead or make enough money that their children would have more than they did. And these were not sophisticated goals, but they were legible. And you could measure your progress. You could tell whether you were succeeding or failing. The story had a shape. All of these previous periods of American history had left us with profound myths. America had inherited the rugged self-made man mythology from the frontier of the West. This was a myth that built the country, the belief that an individual through sheer willpower and physical endurance could carve out a destiny in the wilderness. But in the 1920s, the story had lost.
前一代人知道自己在做什么。他们要去征服边疆，修建铁路，建立家园，或者赚足够的钱让孩子们比自己过得更好。这些目标并不复杂，但它们是清晰可见的。你可以衡量自己的进步。你可以判断自己是在成功还是失败。这个故事是有形状的。所有这些之前的美国历史时期都给我们留下了深刻的神话。美国继承了来自西部边疆的坚毅自立者神话。这是一个建立国家的迷思，即相信个人通过纯粹的意志力和身体耐力，就能在荒野中开辟出命运。但在20世纪20年代，这个故事失去了形状。
its shape. The frontier was closed, the railroads were built, the great industrial projects were complete, and America had become the most productive economy in human history, and nobody knew what to do next. The surplus of the roaring 20s had become an end unto itself until that end, when it became infinitely attainable, became ultimately meaningless, and failed to provide meaning. The nation didn't know where to go anymore, but it still inherited that old frontier mythology and desperately struggled to apply it to a new situation. You can't be a rugged frontiersman in a windowless factory. It's also hard to feel like your self-made or that you're a hero. The Western genre would come back in 1935, but at the time in 1920 it was too new. The
边疆关闭了，铁路修好了，伟大的工业项目完成了，美国已成为人类历史上生产力最高的经济体，而没人知道下一步该做什么。咆哮的20年代的剩余价值成了目的本身，直到这个目的在变得无限可得时，最终变得毫无意义，无法提供意义。这个国家不再知道该往哪里去，但它仍然继承了那个古老的边疆神话，并拼命地试图将其应用于新的处境。你无法在没有窗户的工厂里做一个坚毅的边疆开拓者。也很难觉得自己是自立的，或者觉得自己是个英雄。西部片类型会在1935年回归，但在1920年，它还太新了。
frontier had just closed, and this was recent memory. The hero myth was sort of projected into true crime novels where there were detectives like Philip Marlowe, but the nation struggled to see itself as a hero or to find a hero within itself. After the myth of the self-made man became so infused with their identity, Americans felt alienated or impoverished by these massive new industrial bureaucracies. They didn't blame the system, but they internalized the failure. And so psychology had inherited a new problem, not its fault, but let, again, what would be tasked with fixing. Why don't you remember? I'm your pal. Say, buddy, can you spare a dime?
边疆刚刚关闭，这还是近期的记忆。英雄神话被投射到了硬汉派犯罪小说中，那里有像菲利普·马洛这样的侦探，但这个国家很难将自己视为英雄，也很难在自身内部找到英雄。在自立者神话深深融入他们的身份后，美国人感到被这些庞大的新工业官僚机构所疏远或贫困化。他们没有责怪体制，而是将失败内化了。于是心理学继承了一个新问题，这不是它的错，但它再次被赋予了解决问题的任务。你为什么不记得？我是你的伙伴。嘿，伙计，能借我一角钱吗？
The question that would define the next two decades was deceptively simple. Could psychology provide the explanatory power that religion, tradition, and communal narrative had once supplied? Could it tell Americans who they were, or where they were going? The answer, it turned out, was complicated. Psychology could offer explanations, but the explanations it offered were often too dark, too strange, too honest, or too unflattering about what they said about human nature. Americans wouldn't fully embrace them. And so it began a 20-year struggle
定义接下来二十年的问题简单得令人困惑。心理学能否提供宗教、传统和公共叙事曾经提供的解释力？它能告诉美国人他们是谁，或者他们要去向何方吗？事实证明，答案很复杂。心理学可以提供解释，但它提供的解释往往太黑暗、太奇怪、太诚实，或者对人性而言太不讨喜。美国人不会完全接受它们。于是，一场为期20年的斗争开始了。
between what psychology actually discovered about the human mind and what Americans were willing to accept. But that says nothing compared to what happens when our ideas begin to trickle through in whatever garbled form that relayed to the public. The denials, the frenzy, the incoherent rage.
在心理学对人类心灵的实际发现与美国人愿意接受的内容之间。但这与当我们的想法以任何扭曲的形式传达给公众时所发生的事情相比，根本不算什么。那些否认、狂热和语无伦次的愤怒。
But might that not be caused by your insistence in an exclusively sexual interpretation of the clinical material? All I'm doing is pointing out what experience indicates to me must be the truth. And I can assure you that in a hundred years' time, our work will still be rejected. Columbus, you know, had no idea what country he'd discovered. Like him, I'm in the dark. All I know is I've set foot on the shore, and the country exists.
但那难道不是因为你坚持对临床材料进行排他性的性解释吗？我所做的只是指出经验向我表明必须是真相的东西。我可以向你保证，一百年后，我们的工作仍会被拒绝。你知道，哥伦布根本不知道他发现了哪个国家。像他一样，我身处黑暗之中。我只知道我已经踏上了海岸，而这个国家确实存在。
In the winter of 1909, Sigmund Freud stepped off a steamship in New York Harbor and looked up at the skyline of Manhattan. Perhaps apocryphly, he turned to his traveling companion, Carl Jung, and said, They don't realize we are bringing with us the plague. Whether or not he said it, Freud was wrong. America did not succumb to the plague. America domesticated it. Freud's 1909 visit was brief.
1909年冬天，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德走下纽约港的一艘轮船，抬头望向曼哈顿的天际线。也许是传闻，他转向他的旅伴卡尔·荣格说：“他们没有意识到，我们带来的是瘟疫。”无论他是否说过这句话，弗洛伊德都错了。美国没有屈服于瘟疫。美国驯化了它。弗洛伊德1909年的访问很短暂。
He delivered a series of lectures at Clark University in Massachusetts, introduced American audiences to the basics of psychoanalysis, and then he returned to Vienna, convinced that Americans were too shallow, too optimistic, and too obsessed with money to truly understand what he was offering. But the ideas stayed. One of the issues that psychology had encountered before is that Americans under an advertising regime that incorporated psychology
他在马萨诸塞州的克拉克大学发表了一系列演讲，向美国听众介绍了精神分析的基础知识，然后他回到了维也纳，确信美国人太肤浅、太乐观，且太痴迷于金钱，无法真正理解他所提供的东西。但这些想法留了下来。心理学之前遇到的问题之一是，在美国的广告体制下，心理学被纳入其中。
were losing the ability to tell the difference between what was real and what could be bought. If it wasn't bought, it couldn't be commodified. Maybe it didn't exist. What Americans saw in psychoanalysis where Freud saw a philosophy was a product. And over the next three decades, psychology would spread, through American culture in ways that Freud never anticipated and would come to deplore.
人们正在失去区分真实与可购买之物的能力。如果它买不到，它就无法被商品化。也许它就不存在。美国人在精神分析中看到的——弗洛伊德视为哲学的东西——是一个产品。在接下来的三十年里，心理学将以弗洛伊德从未预料到且后来会谴责的方式，在美国文化中传播开来。
The real migration came later, under far darker circumstances. When the Nazis annexed Austria in 1938, Freud was 82 years old and dying of cancer. His books had already been burned in Berlin, and his daughter Anna was becoming a psychologist in her own right. Through the intervention of powerful friends, Freud escaped to London. He died there in 1939, but psychoanalysis itself had already begun its journey across the Atlantic. Throughout the 1930s, as fascism spread across Europe, a generation of Jewish analysts fled to America. They carried with them not just Freud's theories, but an entire intellectual tradition, a way of thinking about the human mind that had been developed in the coffee houses of Vienna and the consulting rooms of Berlin. They traveled in New York, mostly,
真正的移民潮发生在后来，在更黑暗的环境下。1938年纳粹吞并奥地利时，弗洛伊德已经82岁，且患有癌症。他的书已经在柏林被焚烧，他的女儿安娜也成为了一名心理学家。在强大朋友的干预下，弗洛伊德逃到了伦敦。他于1939年在那里去世，但精神分析本身已经开始了跨越大西洋的旅程。整个20世纪30年代，随着法西斯主义在欧洲蔓延，一代犹太分析师逃往美国。他们带来的不仅是弗洛伊德的理论，还有整个知识传统，一种在维也纳咖啡馆和柏林咨询室中发展起来的关于人类心灵的思考方式。他们主要在纽约旅行。
and they set up practices in the Upper West Side and in Greenwich Village. They trained American doctors in the psychoanalytic method, and they discovered to their frustration and fascination that Americans wanted something from psychoanalysis that it was not designed to provide. Actually, it's a fairly well-established psychological principle that society has a death wish. And if we could just tap into that, the market potential is... What the hell are you talking about? Are you insane? To understand why psychoanalysis struggled in America at first, you have to understand what Freud was actually claiming about the human mind. Freud's fundamental insight was not that sex was important.
他们在上西区和格林威治村开设了诊所。他们用精神分析法培训美国医生，并沮丧而着迷地发现，美国人想要从精神分析中得到的东西，并不是它被设计用来提供的。其实，社会有一种死亡愿望是一个相当成熟的心理学原则。如果我们能利用这一点，市场潜力是……你在胡说什么？你疯了吗？要理解为什么精神分析最初在美国举步维艰，你必须理解弗洛伊德对人类心灵的真正主张。弗洛伊德的基本洞察并不是性很重要。
That was the part that scandalized Victorian audiences and made for good headlines. The deeper, more interesting claim was that human beings are not masters of their own houses. Beneath the conscious mind, Freud argued, lies a vast unconscious territory populated by desires, fears, and memories that we cannot access directly. And these unconscious forces do not disappear simply because we can't see them. They shape our behavior, our relationships, our choices, often in ways that we find horrifying if we understood them. We are in a very real sense strangers to ourselves. More troubling for America still, Freud believed that civilization itself rests on repression. The drives that make social life possible are the same drives that uncontrolled would tear society apart.
那是让维多利亚时代的听众感到震惊并制造出好标题的部分。更深层、更有趣的主张是，人类不是自己房子的主人。弗洛伊德认为，在意识之下，存在着一个广阔的无意识领域，里面充满了我们无法直接获取的欲望、恐惧和记忆。这些无意识的力量并不会因为我们看不见它们就消失。它们塑造了我们的行为、关系和选择，往往以一种如果我们理解了就会感到恐惧的方式。从某种真实的意义上说，我们对自己是陌生人。对美国来说更令人不安的是，弗洛伊德认为文明本身建立在压抑之上。使社会生活成为可能的驱动力，同样也是如果不加控制就会撕裂社会的驱动力。
We learn to redirect our aggression into competition, our sexuality into romance, and our death wish into religion. But the redirection is never complete. The repressed material does not disappear. It returns in symptoms, in dreams, in slips of the time. and the thousand smaller rationalities that punctuate daily life that Freud would analyze. I saw him drop the wheel on the roof. Suddenly I was running. Then I heard something beating over my head. It was a great pair of wings. The wings chased me and almost caught up with me when I came to the bottom of the hill.
我们学会将攻击性转化为竞争，将性欲转化为浪漫，将死亡愿望转化为宗教。但这种重定向从未完全成功。被压抑的材料并没有消失。它以症状、梦境、口误的形式回归，以及弗洛伊德将要分析的那些点缀日常生活的成千上万个微小的非理性行为。我看到他把轮子掉在屋顶上。突然我开始奔跑。然后我听到头顶上方有什么东西在拍打。那是一对巨大的翅膀。当我跑到山脚下时，翅膀追赶着我，差点就抓住了我。
However, despite all of the weirdness of Freud using sexuality as a bulwark to batter Victorian morality, and aside from the sexual theories, there were structural roots for what we know today is attachment therapy. When Freud talked about the edible complex, it wasn't strictly that the people just wanted to have sex with their parents. At a much deeper level, it was that people wanted to become them, because the parent was the only available model for what a human being could be. And we absorbed their neuroses because we are desperately trying to attach to them, to become like them, to handle the world the way that they handle it. This flawed but crucial insight paved the way for much better thinkers, like Winnicott and Karen Horny, who would later strip away the reductive sexual dogmas and build the relational psychodynamic therapy that we still practice today. By the 1920s, Freud had developed his structural model of the
然而，尽管弗洛伊德利用性作为堡垒来冲击维多利亚道德观显得很怪异，除了性理论之外，还有我们今天所知的依恋疗法的结构性根源。当弗洛伊德谈论俄狄浦斯情结时，并不是说人们只是想和父母发生性关系。在更深层面上，人们是想成为他们，因为父母是人类可能成为什么的唯一可用模型。我们吸收了他们的神经症，因为我们拼命地试图依附于他们，变得像他们一样，以他们处理世界的方式来处理世界。这种有缺陷但至关重要的洞察力为温尼科特和卡伦·霍妮等更好的思想家铺平了道路，他们后来剥离了还原论的性教条，建立了我们今天仍在实践的关系动力学疗法。到了20世纪20年代，弗洛伊德发展了他的结构模型。
mind, the id, the primitive reservoir of desires, the ego, the reality-testing conscious self, and the super-ego, the internalized voice of the parental and social authority. He had also introduced the concept of the death drive, Thanato, a fundamental tendency towards destruction that he believed was as basic to human nature as the sexual drive. This was not an optimistic psychology, for we did not believe that people could be cured of their neuroses. The best one could hope for was to transform hysterical misery into ordinary unhappiness. In some of Freud's letters to colleagues, he writes in a derogatory fashion about patients, calling them the fuel for the undiscovered country of psychoanalysis to be discovered,
心灵模型：本我（欲望的原始蓄水池）、自我（现实检验的意识自我）和超我（父母和社会权威的内化声音）。他还引入了死亡驱动（塔纳托斯）的概念，即他认为与性驱动一样是人性基础的破坏倾向。这不是一种乐观的心理学，因为我们不相信人们可以治愈他们的神经症。一个人能希望的最好结果，就是将歇斯底里的痛苦转化为普通的忧郁。在弗洛伊德写给同事的一些信中，他以贬义的方式谈论病人，称他们为精神分析这片未被发现的土地的燃料，
meaning that they would pay for his lifestyle so that he could study them. He failed even at times to see it as a medical intervention, more of a process of discovering the mind. In Freud's eyes, the unconscious could not be conquered. It could only be partially illuminated. And for Americans raised on optimism, progress, and the belief that any problem could be solved with sufficient effort, this was too nihilistic. It was too European. It was too dark. And they wanted the tools without the philosophy. America would use this vocabulary to build a new hero myth of the mind. What is popularity made of anyway?
意思是他们会为他的生活方式买单，以便他能研究他们。他甚至有时没能将其视为一种医疗干预，而更多地将其视为一种发现心灵的过程。在弗洛伊德眼中，无意识无法被征服。它只能被部分照亮。对于在乐观、进步和相信只要付出足够努力就能解决任何问题的信念下长大的美国人来说，这太虚无主义了。这太欧洲化了。这太黑暗了。他们想要工具，却不想要哲学。美国将利用这种词汇来构建一种新的心灵英雄神话。受欢迎到底是由什么构成的？
How does a person get to be popular with lots of people and have a few close friends too? Hey Jerry, there's that new girl in our math class. Oh, yes. My name's Carolyn Ames. She's a swell kid. Why? Do you know her? Not very well.
一个人如何才能受到许多人的欢迎，同时又拥有几个亲密的朋友？嘿，杰瑞，我们数学课上有个新来的女孩。哦，是的。我叫卡罗琳·艾姆斯。她是个很棒的孩子。怎么了？你认识她吗？不太熟。
I wish I did. Yeah, especially when you compare it with some of the weird characters in this place. Yoo-hoo! While psychoanalysis was spreading through elite circles, a very different psychological project was transforming American society, the creation of statistical normalcy. In 1945, a Cleveland physician named Dr. Robert Lattow Dickinson and a sculptor named Abraham Belski unveiled two statues they called Norma and Norman. These figures were not idealized beauties or heroic archetypes. They were composites built from the average measurements of thousands of American bodies. Norma represented the statistical average American woman, and Norman represented the statistical average American man.
我希望我认识。是的，特别是当你把它和这个地方的一些怪人相比时。哟吼！当精神分析在精英圈子中传播时，一个截然不同的心理学项目正在改变美国社会：统计学常态的创造。1945年，克利夫兰医生罗伯特·拉托·迪金森和雕塑家亚伯拉罕·贝尔斯基揭幕了两座他们称之为“诺玛”和“诺曼”的雕像。这些人物并非理想化的美女或英雄原型。它们是由数千个美国人身体的平均测量值构建而成的复合体。诺玛代表了统计学上的平均美国女性，诺曼代表了统计学上的平均美国男性。
The statues were celebrated as triumphs of scientific measurement. Here, finally, was an objective standard to which Americans could measure themselves. The Cleveland Plain Dealer even sponsored a contest to find the real woman whose body most clearly matched Norman's proportions. Thousands of women submitted their measurements, and no winner was ever found. No actual woman matched the statistical average. And this should have been a clue. The normal was a mathematical abstraction, not a description of real human beings, definitely not a goal, and not a replacement for America's hero myth. But the concept had already escaped the laboratory.
这些雕像被誉为科学测量的胜利。终于，这里有了一个客观标准，美国人可以以此来衡量自己。克利夫兰《平原经销商报》甚至赞助了一场比赛，寻找身体最符合诺曼比例的真实女性。成千上万的女性提交了她们的测量数据，但从未找到获胜者。没有一个真实的女性符合统计学平均值。这本该是一个线索。常态是一个数学抽象，而不是对真实人类的描述，绝对不是一个目标，也不是美国英雄神话的替代品。但这个概念已经逃离了实验室。
By the 1920s and 30s, the statistical definition of normalcy had become the goal of American psychology. The discipline's mandate shifted from treating the sick to defining and enforcing the normal. This myth of normal became a fiercely weaponized concept. It was highly weaponized against women who were not allowed to point out exactly what was normal. about their own lived experiences, and the definition of normalcy was entirely controlled by a medical patriarchy to keep the client compliant, to keep the weirdness away, to stop the other from creeping in. A Stepford Wives style psychological containment. But the myth of normal was equally weaponized to gut men. Normal for a man was defined as being stoic, unemotional, hyperproductive, underthought.
到了20世纪20年代和30年代，常态的统计学定义已成为美国心理学的目标。该学科的任务从治疗病人转向定义和强制执行常态。这种常态神话成了一个被激烈武器化的概念。它被高度武器化，用来对付那些不允许指出自己生活经历中到底什么是“正常”的女性，而常态的定义完全由医疗父权制控制，以保持客户的顺从，驱散怪异，阻止“他者”潜入。一种《复制娇妻》式的心理遏制。但常态神话同样被武器化来摧毁男性。男性的常态被定义为坚忍、无情绪、超高产、不思考。
And when the Great Depression hit, this manufactured myth of male normalcy, structurally crushed men, leaving without a psychological framework to process their own economic castration. This was a subtle but profound transformation. In the old world, there were the sane and the insane, the healthy and the diseased, and the categories were relatively clear. But the invention of the statistical normal created a vast new territory, the not quite normal. And you might not be clinically ill, but you might be anxious in ways that fell outside of the standard deviation.
当大萧条来袭时，这种人为制造的男性常态神话在结构上摧毁了男性，使他们没有心理框架来处理自己的经济阉割。这是一个微妙但深刻的转变。在旧世界，有理智与疯狂，健康与疾病，类别相对清晰。但统计学常态的发明创造了一个广阔的新领域：不完全正常。你可能没有临床疾病，但你可能会以超出标准差的方式感到焦虑。
Your personality might deviate from your mean. Your intelligence or your emotional. your sexual desires might fall on the wrong part of the bell curve and the new psychology was less interested in curing dramatic pathologies than in adjusting these subtle deviations and it was the goal was to help Americans become more normal to move towards the center of the distribution to smooth out their eccentricities to become more like the statistical composite that no actual person resembled but this just didn't create conformity it created hyper atomization
你的个性可能偏离了平均值。你的智力或你的情感、你的性欲可能落在钟形曲线的错误部分，而新的心理学对治愈戏剧性的病理学兴趣不大，更感兴趣的是调整这些微妙的偏差。其目标是帮助美国人变得更“正常”，向分布中心移动，抚平他们的怪癖，变得更像那个没有任何真实人物与之相似的统计学复合体。但这并没有创造出一致性，它创造了极度的原子化。
At the same time that you were striving to be normal, you were also striving to be more normal and better at being normal than everyone around you. It put the American psyche into a paradoxical and insane state of competition. It birthed the modern suburb. This was a psychology perfectly suited for mass production and mass marketing. Not only did you need to buy a whole lot of stuff to do everything yourself like power tools, you also needed to buy a whole lot of stuff to make sure that you could do it better than the person next to you, which meant that you had to buy nicer stuff. If you could define normal, you could manufacture products for it,
在你努力变得正常的同时，你也努力变得比周围每个人都更正常、更擅长变得正常。它使美国人的心理陷入了一种矛盾而疯狂的竞争状态。它催生了现代郊区。这是一种非常适合大规模生产和大众营销的心理学。你不仅需要购买大量东西来自己做所有事情，比如电动工具，你还需要购买大量东西来确保你能比隔壁的人做得更好，这意味着你必须购买更好的东西。如果你能定义正常，你就能为它制造产品，
and if you could identify who deviated from normal, then you could sell them solutions. Whether or not you were normal meant that you needed to buy a product. The middle of the bell curve became the target market for everything from soap to psychotherapy. Mrs. Will Thompson bought a frigidaire with super freezer. The neighbors and friends learned of this new oasis and brought their butter, milk, and eggs for safekeeping.
如果你能识别出谁偏离了正常，那么你就能向他们出售解决方案。你是否正常意味着你需要购买产品。钟形曲线的中间成了从肥皂到心理治疗等一切产品的目标市场。威尔·汤普森夫人买了一台带超级冷冻室的冰箱。邻居和朋友们知道了这个新绿洲，把他们的黄油、牛奶和鸡蛋拿来存放。
The migration to America did not just transform psychoanalysis. It also determined which versions of depth psychology would flourish and which would be marginalized. Freud was not the only game in town. By the 1920s, two of his most brilliant former disciples had broken with him and developed their own approaches, Alfred Adler and Carl Jung. Both offered visions of the human mind that were in many ways more compatible with American sensibilities than Freud's pessimistic theory. But neither would achieve the heights that psychoanalysis would reach. Alfred Adler was the first major defector from Freud's inner circle.
向美国的移民不仅改变了精神分析。它还决定了哪些深层心理学版本会蓬勃发展，哪些会被边缘化。弗洛伊德并不是唯一的玩家。到了20世纪20年代，他最杰出的两名前弟子已经与他决裂，并发展了自己的方法：阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒和卡尔·荣格。两人都提供了对人类心灵的愿景，在许多方面比弗洛伊德的悲观理论更符合美国人的情感。但两者都没有达到精神分析所能达到的高度。阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒是弗洛伊德核心圈子中第一个主要的叛逃者。
He had developed what he called individual psychology. Where Freud emphasized the primacy of sexual drives, Adler focused on the social nature of human beings. His central concept was the inferiority complex, the universal human experience of feeling inadequate, and the equal universal striving to compensate. Adler's psychology was fundamentally optimistic. He believed that people could change, could grow,
他发展了所谓的“个体心理学”。弗洛伊德强调性驱动的首要地位，而阿德勒则关注人类的社会本质。他的核心概念是“自卑情结”，即人类普遍感到不足的体验，以及同样普遍的补偿努力。阿德勒的心理学本质上是乐观的。他相信人们可以改变，可以成长，
and could develop their social feeling, and become contributing members of society. contributing members of society. He was interested in education, in child rearing, in the prevention of mental illness, through the creation of supportive community, and he ran guidance clinics in Vienna that were models of democratic accessible mental health care. And this should have appealed to Americans, and in many ways it did. Adler was enormously popular in the United States during his lifetime. He lectured widely, and he trained American therapist and influenced a generation of educators and social workers. The concept of the inferiority complex entered the common speech.
可以发展他们的社会情感，并成为社会的贡献者。他关注教育、儿童抚养、通过建立支持性社区来预防精神疾病，他在维也纳经营的指导诊所是民主、可及的心理健康护理的典范。这本应吸引美国人，在许多方面确实如此。阿德勒在世时在美国非常受欢迎。他广泛演讲，培训美国治疗师，并影响了一代教育工作者和社会工作者。自卑情结的概念进入了日常用语。
but Adler never achieved institutional dominance. He had no powerful organization to promote his ideas. He refused to establish the kind of training institutes that Freudians would build, and he was more interested in reaching ordinary people than creating an elite priesthood of analysts. And so after his death in 37, his ideas dispersed. Carl Jung's fate was different but equally instructive. Jung had been Freud's closest successor, the crown prince of psychoanalysis, until their dramatic break in 1913. You could not accept Freud's insistence that sexuality was the primary human drive. He believed that there was something more, something deeper, a spiritual dimension to the psyche that Freud's materialism could not accommodate. The subjectivity akin to William James.
但阿德勒从未获得制度上的主导地位。他没有强大的组织来推广他的想法。他拒绝建立弗洛伊德派那样的培训机构，他更感兴趣的是接触普通人，而不是创造一个精英分析师祭司阶层。因此，在他37年去世后，他的思想分散了。卡尔·荣格的命运不同，但同样具有启发性。荣格曾是弗洛伊德最亲密的继任者，精神分析的皇太子，直到他们1913年的戏剧性决裂。你无法接受弗洛伊德坚持认为性是人类的主要驱动力。他相信还有更多的东西，更深层的东西，一种弗洛伊德的唯物主义无法容纳的心理精神维度。一种类似于威廉·詹姆斯的主观性。
Which is why I ask us all to raise our glasses tonight. To wish Dr. Freud, Dr. Young, and Dr. Adler the very best of luck in their new science. Ladies and gentlemen. May I ask you, what did you find was the most fascinating moment of the conference? When they declared my theories had nothing to do with science, that instead were a matter for the police. It's because everything you say is couched in biological terms. Well, I suppose you would rather I spoke with the spirit.
这就是为什么我请大家今晚举杯。祝愿弗洛伊德博士、荣格博士和阿德勒博士在他们的新科学中好运。女士们，先生们。我可以问问你们，你们觉得会议中最迷人的时刻是什么吗？当他们宣布我的理论与科学无关，而是一个警察管辖的问题时。那是因为你所说的一切都用生物学术语表达。好吧，我想你宁愿我谈论精神。
Maybe. But what is spirit? Everything. No. Everything that shows what you call spirit has more to do with repressive. sexuality. Please, gentlemen, not in the middle of the descent. Our culture is our spirit, our whole civilization. Civilization, Colin. And don't tell me, it's just a consequence of repressed sexuality. Yes, I'm afraid it is. The whole dilemma of power, heroes and love seems to be never
也许。但什么是精神？一切。不。所有表现出你所谓精神的东西，都与压抑的性欲有更多关系。请，先生们，不要在下降的过程中。我们的文化就是我们的精神，我们的整个文明。文明，科林。别告诉我，这只是压抑性欲的结果。是的，恐怕就是这样。关于权力、英雄和爱的整个困境似乎永远
ending. Well, to quote you, Carl, the pendulum of the mind swings between sense and nonsense, not between white and wrong. the psychological development was not simply about adjusting to society. It was about individual integration, taking all of the parts of self and then making them understood or conscious so that they could become part of a bigger whole. The process itself was essentially spiritual, and this was too mystical for American medicine. Jung's ideas appealed to artists, writers, theologians, and seekers of various kinds. Joseph Campbell, who had spent the 1930s and 1940s developing his theory of the hero's journey to be published in the 50s, was deeply influenced by Jung's concept of archetypes.
没完没了。好吧，引用你的话，卡尔，心灵的钟摆在理智与无理智之间摆动，而不是在对与错之间。心理发展不仅仅是适应社会。它是关于个体整合，将自我的所有部分拿出来，然后使它们被理解或意识化，以便它们能成为更大整体的一部分。这个过程本质上是精神性的，这对美国医学来说太神秘了。荣格的思想吸引了艺术家、作家、神学家和各种寻求者。约瑟夫·坎贝尔在20世纪30年代和40年代致力于发展他的英雄之旅理论，该理论将在50年代出版，深受荣格原型概念的影响。
But the medical establishment viewed Jung with suspicion. His embrace of religion, his interest in alchemy and mythology, his interest in the psyche, and the spiritual dimension made him seem unscientific, including his inability to produce any metrics. Publishing broad theories and case studies, he stayed away from quantified data. And here we must pause and look at a terrifying parallel. In the previous episode, we saw how American psychology desperately insecure and craving the authority of hard science murdered its own father, William James. James embraced the stream of consciousness in the mystical, and he was replaced by John Watson, who offered the sterile, mechanicalistic illusion of control. Across the Atlantic, the exact same tragedy played out between Sigmund Freud
但医学界对荣格持怀疑态度。他对宗教的拥抱、对炼金术和神话的兴趣、对心灵和精神维度的兴趣，使他看起来不科学，包括他无法产生任何指标。他发表广泛的理论和案例研究，远离量化数据。在这里，我们必须停下来看看一个可怕的平行现象。在上一集中，我们看到美国心理学如何因极度不安全感和对硬科学权威的渴望而谋杀了它自己的父亲威廉·詹姆斯。詹姆斯拥抱意识流和神秘主义，他被约翰·华生取代，后者提供了无菌、机械化的控制幻觉。在大西洋彼岸，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德和卡尔·荣格之间上演了完全相同的悲剧。
and Carl Jung, and this dynamic was not simply capitalism binding the world. It was about psychology itself becoming profoundly insecure. Freud was terrified that if so psychoanalysis embraced the spiritual or the uncomputable, it would be dismissed by the rigid medical establishment. He was largely right, and Freud famously warned you that they must take a dogma of sexual theory to act as a bulwark against the black mud of occultism. Freud and Watson were the institutional enforcers. They pushed the mystery of the human soul away to protect their fragile academic effects. And James and Jung were the expansive, messy, mystical explorers who were excommunicated because their ideas couldn't be quantified, controlled, or easily monetized by the emerging technocratic state. This also has a parallel in what would happen in the 1980s and 90s, when cognitive and behavioral therapy would largely replace psychodynamic and somatic therapy as objective metrics to push away some of the weirdness of the mindfulness-based New Age movement.
这种动态不仅仅是资本主义在束缚世界。这是关于心理学本身变得极度不安全。弗洛伊德非常害怕，如果精神分析拥抱精神或不可计算的东西，它会被僵化的医学界所摒弃。他基本上是对的，弗洛伊德曾著名地警告荣格，他们必须采取性理论的教条，作为抵御神秘主义黑泥的堡垒。弗洛伊德和华生是制度执行者。他们推开了人类灵魂的奥秘，以保护他们脆弱的学术资产。而詹姆斯和荣格是广阔、混乱、神秘的探索者，他们被逐出教会，因为他们的想法无法被量化、控制或被新兴的技术官僚国家轻易货币化。这也与80年代和90年代发生的事情有相似之处，当时认知和行为疗法在很大程度上取代了心理动力学和躯体疗法，作为客观指标来推开正念冥想新时代运动的一些怪异之处。
when Eastern philosophy would cross-contaminate psychotherapy in California in this early 60s. While traditional psychoanalysis debated sexual drives and Oedipus complexes, a German psychoanalyst named Karen Hornay arrived in the U.S. in 1932 and saw something far more urgent. Hornay realized that in a terrifying environment, human beings are not primarily motivated by primitive drives. They're motivated by the need for security, for love, and what she called basic trust. Unlike Watson, she didn't think that every variable of the environment could control a person, but unlike Freud and Jung, she didn't think that basic inborn drives needed to be discovered in the unconscious. She saw the roots of human attachment to the parent in early childhood as the thing that had the most explaining power about human behavior in adults.
当东方哲学在60年代初在加利福尼亚与心理治疗交叉污染时。当传统的精神分析争论性驱动和俄狄浦斯情结时，一位名叫卡伦·霍妮的德国精神分析学家于1932年抵达美国，看到了更紧迫的事情。霍妮意识到，在恐怖的环境中，人类并不是主要由原始驱动力驱动的。他们是由对安全、爱和她所谓的“基本信任”的需求所驱动的。与华生不同，她不认为环境的每一个变量都能控制一个人，但与弗洛伊德和荣格不同，她不认为基本的先天驱动力需要在无意识中被发现。她将童年早期对父母的人类依恋根源视为对成人人类行为最具解释力的东西。
Back to the matter, Muley, after what them dust has done to the land, the tenant system don't work no more. They don't even break even, much less show a profit. By one man on the tractor can handle 12 or 14 of these places. You just pay them a wage and take all the crop. Yeah, but we couldn't do on any less than what our share is now. Well, the children ain't getting enough to eat as it is. And they're so ragged. We'd be ashamed if everybody else's children wasn't the same way.
回到正题，穆利，在那些尘土对土地造成破坏之后，佃农制度不再起作用了。他们甚至无法收支平衡，更不用说盈利了。拖拉机上的一个人可以处理这些地方的12或14个。你只是付给他们工资，拿走所有的庄稼。是的，但我们的份额比现在少的话，我们无法生存。嗯，孩子们现在连饭都吃不饱。他们衣衫褴褛。如果别人的孩子不是这样，我们会感到羞耻。
I can't help that. All I know is I got my orders. They told me to tell you to get off, and that's what I'm telling you. You mean get off from my own land? I don't go to blaming me. It ain't my fault. Whose fault is it? You know who owns the land, the Shawnee Land and Cattle Company. And who's the Shawnee Land and Cattle Company? It ain't nobody, it's a company.
我帮不了这个忙。我只知道我接到了命令。他们让我告诉你离开，这就是我告诉你的。你是说让我离开我自己的土地？别怪我。这不是我的错。是谁的错？你知道谁拥有这片土地，肖尼土地和牛业公司。肖尼土地和牛业公司是谁？它不是任何人，它是一家公司。
They got a president, ain't they? They got somebody in those one of shotguns for, ain't they? Oh, son, it ain't his fault because the bank tells him what to do. All right. Where's the bank? Tulsa. What's the use of picking on him? He ain't nothing but the manager. And he's half crazy as self trying to keep up with his orders from the East. Then who do we shoot?
他们有总裁，不是吗？他们有人拿着猎枪，不是吗？哦，孩子，这不是他的错，因为银行告诉他该怎么做。好吧。银行在哪里？塔尔萨。挑他的刺有什么用？他只不过是个经理。他自己也快疯了，试图跟上来自东方的命令。那我们该射击谁？
Brother, I don't know. If I did, I'd tell him. did I tell you. In the middle of the 1930s, America was a fundamentally unsaved place. The frontier was dead, the economy had collapsed, and the nation was suspended in a terrifying void, desperately waiting for a new hero myth to save them. In the winter of 1933, President Franklin Roosevelt addressed the American people. His fireside chats were not a traditional speech.
兄弟，我不知道。如果我知道，我会告诉你的。我告诉你了吗？在20世纪30年代中期，美国是一个根本不安全的地方。边疆已死，经济崩溃，国家悬浮在一个可怕的虚空中，拼命等待一个新的英雄神话来拯救他们。1933年冬天，富兰克林·罗斯福总统向美国人民发表讲话。他的炉边谈话不是传统的演讲。
They were intimate conversations delivered through a medium that had just transformed the country. The media theorist Walter Ong called radio the beginning of a secondary or rhaps. It created a voice without a body, intimate without presence, creating the sensation of personal connection across impossible distance. Radio created a parasycial relationship, the profound feeling of knowing someone that you would never actually met. And this was a massive nationwide attachment play. It was only because of the sheer economic terror of the Great Depression that this medium
它们是通过一种刚刚改变了国家的媒介进行的亲密对话。媒体理论家沃尔特·翁称广播为“次要口语”的开始。它创造了一种没有身体的声音，没有存在感的亲密，创造了跨越不可能距离的个人联系感。广播创造了一种准社会关系，一种认识一个你从未真正见过的人的深刻感觉。这是一场大规模的全国性依恋游戏。正是因为大萧条的纯粹经济恐怖，这种媒介
could be stumbled upon and weaponized in this exact way. And a great time of economic surplus, it wouldn't have been needed. But during the Depression, the American male, the traditional pattern from Melius, had been economically castrated. He no longer felt like the provider. Inner FDR. Throughout the radio, the president effectively threw a warm blanket over a freezing and terrified country.
才会被偶然发现并以这种确切的方式武器化。在经济过剩的伟大时代，它是不需要的。但在大萧条期间，美国男性，传统的梅利乌斯模式，在经济上被阉割了。他不再觉得自己是供养者。罗斯福进场了。通过广播，总统有效地给一个寒冷而恐惧的国家披上了一条温暖的毯子。
He got cozy with everybody, making the populace feel like they were snuggling in a bed, listening to a wise, protective grandfather, and he successfully projected the ultimate Jungian archetype of the father, filling the void left by the death of the American hero. But as Jung would understand, this kind of attachment also can have a shadow, the ability for someone to manipulate. Roosevelt wasn't the only one who understood the archetypes that were missing in America, or the powerful new media and cultural realities the technology was allowing. Edward Bernays was Sigmund Freud's nephew, and where Freud was interested in healing, Bernays wanted power. Bernay's core insight drawn directly from depth psychology was that human beings are not rational actors.
他与每个人都变得亲近，让民众感觉他们就像蜷缩在床上，听着一位睿智、保护性的祖父说话，他成功地投射了荣格的终极父亲原型，填补了美国英雄死亡留下的空白。但正如荣格所理解的那样，这种依恋也可能有阴影，即某人操纵的能力。罗斯福并不是唯一一个理解美国缺失的原型，或者技术正在允许的强大新媒体和文化现实的人。爱德华·伯内斯是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的侄子，弗洛伊德对治愈感兴趣，而伯内斯想要权力。伯内斯直接从深层心理学中得出的核心洞察是，人类不是理性的行动者。
To influence mass behavior, you do not appeal to reason, you appeal to instinct, and you manufacture desires that people do not know that they have. Bernays staged spectacles, like having debutants smoke lucky-strike cigarettes, a male behavior being done defiantly by women. It looked organic. The women held up signs saying that they were called torches of freedom, and Bernays had engineered the whole thing. He took a genuine political desire, women's equality,
要影响大众行为，你不能诉诸理性，你诉诸本能，并制造人们不知道自己拥有的欲望。伯内斯策划了奇观，比如让名媛抽好彩香烟，这是一种女性挑衅性地进行的男性行为。它看起来很自然。女性举着牌子说她们被称为“自由火炬”，而伯内斯策划了这一切。他利用了一种真正的政治欲望，即女性平等，
and then redirected it towards a consumer behavior. making them both inseparable. If you wanted female empowerment, you know how to smoke as a woman. The energy of rebellion was captured and commodified, and Bernays was explicit in his 1928 book, Propaganda, writing that the intelligent manipulation of the masses as the true ruling power of the country. The elite were utilizing an archetypal magic,
然后将其重定向到消费行为。使两者不可分割。如果你想要女性赋权，你知道作为女性该如何抽烟。反叛的能量被捕获并商品化了，伯内斯在他1928年的书《宣传》中明确写道，对大众的智能操纵是国家真正的统治力量。精英们正在利用一种原型魔法，
the mother, the hero, the patriarch, to sell soap, cigarettes, and political compliance, hiding behind the veneer of rational PR. Crucially, this engineering would soon extend to selling a suburban home as the ultimate psychological sanctuary. PR firms and developers utilize these exact same mechanisms to equate citizenship and consumption, ensuring that the public was primed to retreat into private consumerist fortresses the moment that the coming war ended. Hello? George, there is a room around town that you close your doors. Is that true?
母亲、英雄、族长，来销售肥皂、香烟和政治合规，隐藏在理性公关的外表之下。至关重要的是，这种工程很快将扩展到将郊区住宅作为终极心理避难所进行销售。公关公司和开发商利用这些完全相同的机制将公民身份和消费等同起来，确保公众在即将到来的战争结束时，准备好撤退到私人消费主义堡垒中。喂？乔治，城里有传言说你关门了。是真的吗？
Oh, well, I'm very glad to hear that. Are you all right? Do you need any police? Police, what for? Well, mobs get pretty ugly sometimes, you know. George, I am going all out to help in this crisis. I have just guaranteed the bank sufficient funds to meet their needs. They will close up for a week and then reopen. Just took over the bank.
哦，好吧，我很高兴听到这个消息。你还好吗？你需要警察吗？警察，为了什么？嗯，暴民有时会变得很丑陋，你知道的。乔治，我正在全力帮助度过这场危机。我刚刚向银行保证了足够的资金来满足他们的需求。他们将关闭一周，然后重新开业。刚接管了银行。
I may lose a fortune, but I am willing to guarantee your people, too. Just tell them to bring their shares over here, and I will pay 50 cents on the dollar. Boy, you never miss a trick, do you, Potter? Or you're going to miss this one. If you close your doors before 6 p.m., you will never reopen. The stock market crash of October 1929 destroyed not just wealth, but the entire American mythology. Millions lost their jobs and homes, and this massive split between the material realities of America and the promises of the American dream led to a profound reorientation.
我可能会损失一笔财富，但我愿意也为你们的人民担保。只要告诉他们把股份带到这里，我会按50美分兑1美元支付。伙计，你从不失手，对吧，波特？或者你会错过这一次。如果你在下午6点前关门，你就永远不会再开业了。1929年10月的股市崩盘不仅摧毁了财富，还摧毁了整个美国神话。数百万人失去了工作和家园，美国物质现实与美国梦承诺之间的这种巨大分裂导致了深刻的重新定位。
The American Dream had been presented like a guaranteed contract, but now the people who had been promised assembly lines were lining up for bread lines. And when that happened, the system didn't blame itself. It started blaming the victim. Before the Great Depression, poverty in America had a very different psychological texture than poverty in the old world. In medieval England or France, poverty was futile. It was a permanent structural class that you were born into. But the American mythos was built on the safety valve of the frontier. poverty was supposed to be a temporary state. If you failed in the east, you could go west.
美国梦曾像一份保证合同一样被呈现，但现在被承诺拥有装配线的人们正在排队领取救济粮。当这种情况发生时，体制并没有责怪自己。它开始责怪受害者。在大萧条之前，美国的贫困与旧世界的贫困有着非常不同的心理质感。在中世纪的英国或法国，贫困是宿命的。这是一个你生来就属于的永久结构性阶级。但美国神话建立在边疆的安全阀之上。贫困本应是一种暂时状态。如果你在东方失败了，你可以去西部。
Upward mobility wasn't just possible. It was the national religion. By the 1930s, the frontier was closed, and the factories were padlocked. Suddenly America found itself with a permanent trapped starving underclass, and for the first time in history, America was staring down the barrel of European-style structural poverty. The stock market crash broke the illusion, and when the psychological pacification of mass media failed to keep starving people docile, the mask slipped. In 1933, wealthy Wall Street elites looked at this new, permanent underclass and became terrified of a European-style communist revolution. In a blind panic, they actually attempted to organize a fascist military coup,
向上流动不仅是可能的，它甚至是美国的国教。到了20世纪30年代，边疆已经消失，工厂也已锁闭。美国突然发现自己陷入了一个永久的、被困的、饥饿的下层阶级中，这是历史上第一次，美国面临着欧洲式的结构性贫困。股市崩盘打破了幻想，当大众媒体的心理安抚无法让饥饿的人群保持顺从时，面具滑落了。1933年，富有的华尔街精英们看着这个新的、永久的下层阶级，开始恐惧欧洲式的共产主义革命。在盲目的恐慌中，他们竟然试图组织一场法西斯军事政变，
the infamous business plot, approaching a retired Marine Corps general, General Smedley Butler, to march an army of veterans on Washington to overthrow FDR's government. The coup was thwarted, but when Butler blew the whistle, the failure of the business, plot taught the American establishment a terrifying and valuable lesson. In a democracy, you can't control a starving, angry, working class with guns and dictatorship. It's too clumsy. It sparks revolution. You have to control their minds. This is why the system doubled down on a new kind of psychological management. If the elites could not use the military to keep the masses in line, then they would find a way to get the masses to keep themselves in line. In the feudal system of Europe, class was based around
即臭名昭著的“商业阴谋”，他们接触了一位退役的海军陆战队少将斯梅德利·巴特勒，试图带领一支退伍军人大军进军华盛顿，推翻富兰克林·罗斯福的政府。政变被挫败了，但当巴特勒揭发此事时，这次商业阴谋的失败给美国建制派上了一堂既可怕又宝贵的一课。在民主制度下，你不能用枪支和独裁来控制饥饿、愤怒的工人阶级。这太笨拙了，会引发革命。你必须控制他们的思想。这就是为什么体制加倍投入了一种新型的心理管理。如果精英们不能利用军队来让大众保持一致，那么他们就会找到一种方法，让大众自己保持一致。在欧洲的封建制度中，阶级是基于
identity, but in America, identity was malleable. If you failed, then the failure must have been your fault. It was this hyper-internalized shame that would collide with the logistical meat grinder of World War II to make the psychology of the next century. When America entered the war, the military establishment faced an unprecedented demand, sorting millions and millions of men. They did not care about the depths of the human soul, and they didn't care about the debates between Freudians and Jungians.
身份的，但在美国，身份是可塑的。如果你失败了，那么失败一定是你自己的错。正是这种高度内化的羞耻感，与第二次世界大战的后勤绞肉机碰撞，塑造了下一个世纪的心理学。当美国参战时，军事机构面临着前所未有的需求，需要对数以百万计的人进行分类。他们不在乎人类灵魂的深度，也不在乎弗洛伊德学派和荣格学派之间的争论。
They just needed metrics. And they needed a standardized baseline of human behavior that could be applied at scale. So they invented the myth of normal that would later come to define the suburbs. To process the chaotic reality of combat trauma, the military forced the creation of a standardized logistical sorting manual for psychiatric casualties. This manual laid the immediate groundwork for what would become the first DSM, or diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. Crucially, this rigid statistical checklist was pushed through against the wishes of the very
他们只需要指标。他们需要一个可以大规模应用的标准化人类行为基准。于是，他们发明了后来定义了郊区的“正常”神话。为了处理战斗创伤的混乱现实，军方强制创建了一本针对精神伤亡的标准化后勤分类手册。这本手册为后来成为第一版《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）奠定了直接基础。至关重要的是，这份僵化的统计清单是在违背了那些
psychiatrist who were forced to draft it. The clinicians knew that human suffering could not be reduced to a spreadsheet, but the spreadsheet had already won. The military's drive to standardize everything led directly into the civilian world in 1945. The discipline of psychology shifted its mandate from exploring the depths of the soul to enforcing the baseline of the normal citizen. And when you combine these two historical forces, the paralyzing shame of the rugged individual self-made man and the idea of the aggressively normal person, you got to the human.
被迫起草它的精神科医生的意愿下被强行推行的。临床医生们知道人类的痛苦不能简化为电子表格，但电子表格已经赢了。军方将一切标准化的动力在1945年直接带入了平民世界。心理学学科将其使命从探索灵魂深处转向了强制执行普通公民的基准。当你将这两种历史力量结合起来——那种坚毅的个人主义者自我造就的瘫痪性羞耻感，以及那种激进的“正常人”观念——你就得到了人类。
got the groundwork for the American suburb. The ultimate absurdity is that absolutely no one working in these psychological systems at this time thought of psychiatry like a system that was objective or quantifiable. Freud, Jung, Adler, none of them. Only John B. Watson and the behaviorists actually believed that you could measure the human mind like a machine. The military establishment grabbed the wriggling aqueous body of the discombobulated scene that was American psychology, and they forced it into the rigid reductivism of the Taylorist,
得到了美国郊区的基石。最荒谬的是，当时在这些心理学系统中工作的绝对没有人认为精神病学是一个客观或可量化的系统。弗洛伊德、荣格、阿德勒，他们中没有一个人这么认为。只有约翰·B·华生和行为主义者真正相信你可以像测量机器一样测量人类的心智。军事机构抓住了美国心理学那扭动、水状、混乱的身体，强行将其塞进了泰勒主义、
the Watsonian behaviorist, and the systems thinkers. Like James had envisioned it, psychotherapy was still a pretty subjective process. It was about the relationship between nodes, the relationships between people, and that blank space was the medicine. The change made at this time would turn the system into symptoms and interventions for the rest of its existence. It's something that nobody planned and that nobody at the time thought was possible, but it happened all without anyone noticing. And if you asked Adler, Freud, or Jung about this, what would they say?
华生行为主义和系统思想家的僵化还原论中。正如詹姆斯所设想的那样，心理治疗仍然是一个相当主观的过程。它关乎节点之间的关系，关乎人与人之间的关系，而那片空白就是药物。当时所做的改变将使该系统在余下的存在时间里变成症状和干预措施。这是没有人计划过、当时也没有人认为可能发生的事情，但它在无人察觉的情况下发生了。如果你问阿德勒、弗洛伊德或荣格对此有何看法，他们会怎么说？
Freudian psychoanalysis was essentially Freud wanting to study people. He thought that there were dark and unreconcilable forces, and your best bet was just to take a little peek at them, think about how powerless you are, appreciate the gravity of that interpretation, and then move on. He would be appalled to see his priest class of interpreters replaced by a checklist. Carl Jung thought that people had distinct parts of self
弗洛伊德的精神分析本质上是弗洛伊德想要研究人。他认为存在着黑暗且不可调和的力量，你最好的办法就是窥探一下它们，思考一下你是多么无力，体会这种解释的沉重感，然后继续前行。如果看到他那神职人员般的解释者阶层被一份清单所取代，他会感到震惊。卡尔·荣格认为人们拥有自我的不同部分，
that played different roles in society and came from different parts of history and different evolutionary needs of a system. And he believed that you should prepare for death as the ultimate state of life, looking for the structure of narrative and the structure of anthropological society to model how a person finds meaning while they move through life and age. You cannot stream for that like a disease. And Alfred Adler thought that our neuroses were internal compensatory mechanisms for social dysfunction
这些部分在社会中扮演着不同的角色，源于历史的不同部分和系统的不同进化需求。他认为你应该为死亡这一生命的终极状态做好准备，寻找叙事结构和人类学社会结构，以模拟一个人在经历生活和衰老时如何寻找意义。你不能像筛查疾病一样筛查这些。而阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒认为，我们的神经症是社会功能障碍的内部补偿机制，
that showed up externally and could be mapped in social interaction. None of this is compatible with the system it's been forced into, but it still uses their language. The terms are still around in the DSM. And there are concepts that are completely irreconcilable with a diagnostic checklist because there are forces that move across time and in between things, not things that can be screened for. And so this bizarre fusion, this deep subjective theory of these three thinkers, violently compressed into the objective metrics of the military and the behaviorists
这种机制在外部表现出来，并可以在社会互动中进行映射。这一切都与它被强行纳入的系统不兼容，但它仍然使用他们的语言。这些术语在DSM中依然存在。有些概念与诊断清单完全不可调和，因为有些力量是在时间中和事物之间移动的，而不是可以被筛查出来的东西。因此，这种奇怪的融合——这三位思想家深刻的主观理论——被暴力地压缩进了军方和行为主义者的客观指标中，
that became what we know today, even though the language doesn't make any sense. And this is the moment that the world actually split. The image of psychology began to divorce from the American reality of psychology. And talking about psychology from this point onward becomes a hall of mirrors. Just like the end of the first episode, we're left living inside of a ghost story here. The theory is forged in 1920 and 1945 and the manufactured normalcy, the behavioral metrics, the lie that systemic poverty is a personal psychological defect, still haunt us today. They still organize our lives, and their conclusions are baking.
这就成了我们今天所知的样子，尽管这些语言根本说不通。这就是世界真正分裂的时刻。心理学的形象开始与美国心理学的现实脱节。从这一点开始谈论心理学就变成了一个镜厅。就像第一集结尾一样，我们生活在一个鬼故事里。这些理论在1920年和1945年锻造而成，那种人为制造的常态、行为指标、关于系统性贫困是个人的心理缺陷的谎言，至今仍在困扰着我们。它们仍然在组织我们的生活，而它们的结论正被烘焙
into the very foundation of modern American psychology, even though our culture has long since canceled their premises, and modern science has found them scientifically useless. We're still being diagnosed by the ghosts of World War II military logisticians. Scientifically, the 1945 pair-up time has been completely obliterated, yet the institutions the governmental health, the American Psychiatric Association, the managed care networks, the university training models, are locked into an infrastructure trap. They cannot abandon these mid-century metrics, metrics because the entire economic architecture of American health care relies on them. And the DSM is not just a clinical document.
进现代美国心理学的根基中，尽管我们的文化早已取消了它们的前提，现代科学也发现它们在科学上毫无用处。我们仍然被二战军事后勤人员的幽灵所诊断。从科学上讲，1945年的配对时间已经被完全抹去，但这些机构——政府卫生部门、美国精神医学学会、管理式医疗网络、大学培训模式——都被锁定在一个基础设施陷阱中。他们无法放弃这些中世纪的指标，因为美国医疗保健的整个经济架构都依赖于它们。而DSM不仅仅是一份临床文件。
It's a financial instrument. And the bureaucracy demands a standardized measurable normal to process claims, allocate resources, and conduct pharmacological research. The ghost of the 1940s isn't a statue or an ideal anymore. It is a statistical mean against which all human suffering must be plotted and build. And this requirement for measurable normalcy combined with the logical efficiency, of the military, created the ultimate pressure cooker, and as the troops came home, this exact combination laid the stage for white flight and the birth of the American suburb. Millions of Americans fled the cities, not just to find a patch of grass, but to frantically
它是一种金融工具。官僚机构需要一个标准化的、可衡量的“正常”来处理索赔、分配资源和进行药理学研究。40年代的幽灵不再是一个雕像或理想。它是一个统计平均值，所有人类的痛苦都必须根据它来绘制和计费。这种对可衡量常态的要求，结合军方的逻辑效率，创造了一个终极压力锅。随着军队回家，这种精确的组合为“白人群体外迁”和美国郊区的诞生奠定了基础。数以百万计的美国人逃离城市，不仅仅是为了寻找一片草地，而是为了疯狂地
prove to the system to their neighbors and to themselves that they fit the metric. In our next episode, we'll follow the ghosts into the 1950s. We'll enter the plastic oasis of the American suburb, and we'll see what happens when the military's normal becomes mandatory, when the mind is reduced to a computer and when a generation desperately tries and fails to break out the little boxes on the hillside. Cold machines, warm ghosts, we're humming under power lines, your soft-set laughing notes
向体制、向邻居、向自己证明他们符合这个指标。在下一集中，我们将跟随这些幽灵进入20世纪50年代。我们将进入美国郊区的塑料绿洲，看看当军方的“正常”成为强制性要求时会发生什么，当思想被简化为计算机时会发生什么，当一代人拼命试图打破山坡上的小盒子却失败时会发生什么。冰冷的机器，温暖的幽灵，我们在电线下嗡嗡作响，你轻柔的笑声
get carried through the tangled wires, cold machines, warm ghosts, you sing in something in you sing, something in you, breaks I'm holding on mistake. Hey guys, thank you for listening to Part 2 of Psychotherapy on the Couch, a Psycho History of American Psychology. If you have not already, please check out our website, gettherapy Birmingham.com,
穿过纠缠的电线，冰冷的机器，温暖的幽灵，你唱着什么，你唱着，你心中的某样东西，破碎了，我正坚持着错误。嘿，伙计们，感谢收听《沙发上的心理治疗：美国心理学心理史》第二部分。如果你还没有收听，请查看我们的网站 gettherapy Birmingham.com，
and consider subscribing to the podcast in your favorite podcast library or on YouTube. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并考虑在你最喜欢的播客库或YouTube上订阅我们的播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。